so the reds on the return
of sonny gray hit the field coming off
that rib cage
injury gray last time out seven
innings only a couple of runs that was
in kansas city against the royals
and he got the win in that outing just
his second of the season the other
came back on may the 27th and now with a
couple of strikes suarez backs up
peterson raises the elbows and he gets
hit by the pitch
look in the final two innings runner on
the move pitch is taken inside good jump
and peterson has second stolen
the late inning work and especially in
the 11th
as ureas lines one into left field of
base hit
peterson will move to third and the
brewers are in business in the opening
inning
tap back to gray he looks home he
hesitates he creates a rundown for
peterson
runs into third the flick
suarez fires to the plate tag
out at home play back side both runners
move up maria's to third yellage to
second
well this is a nice job by sonny gray
with the anticipation of that runner
trying to score
does a nice job of running peterson back
to third base
and he does a nice job of staying in the
pickle long enough
so those trailer runners can get in the
scoring position
rowdy teles in the lineup here this
afternoon gray versus teles a little
threat for the brewers in the opening
inning
and teles gets hit and there's
an rbi the hard way
second hit batter for sonny gray in this
opening inning they take that any day of
the week when the no two cam with the
bases loaded
one two called strike three that's what
gray is so good at
does he try to come in on jackie bradley
jr bases loaded two outs
grounded back to gray
damage minimized corbin burns yeah he's
been
on a roll you know burns last loss was
way back on may 25th against san diego
he's got two wins since that time five
no decisions but his number is
outstanding 128 strikeouts good for
eighth in the national league
gustave got miley to bounce out to win
the game
and winker a swing and a foul tip into
the mid of pina
for out number one 3-1
and that's ripped into right field and a
sliding catch
made by tyrone taylor for out number two
you can't hit it any better than that
good running catch from tyrone he
recognized that line drive right away
i heard you grunting more than normal
finishing on your pitches
2-2 got him looking
fastball away again cold strike three
feel like he just
tough play freeman off balance extends
and makes the catch
he had to go out there he sure did
you know you have a few steps you go out
to the outfield and you say okay
this is a little further than i should
be going that's normally when you looked
up to see where that center fielder is
akiyama was nowhere close got in the
game last night for the brewers reds
used
seven barnard shark comebacker to burns
to up two down even in this day of day
and age of uh using a lot of guys in the
bullpen
13 between the two teams that's still a
lot that's a lot
[Applause]
now that it seems the command is
sharpened mighty start
to incorporate that suarez
settles it india one on a first double
play
well this one doesn't kick off the glove
gino with the
feed to india and the nice transfer
five four three the indians o2 pitch
from burns a swing
and a miss and a strikeout for burns his
second of the day
up elevated the fourth seemer that time
to get him omar narvaez rounding out the
brewers reps and there's
back-to-back strikeouts for burns two
away in the third
the road to the midwest
jonathan india a wave and a miss pena
will secure it as corbin burns strikes
out the side
right before the inning began before we
came back sunny gray
put his keister down on the mound dirt
and rubbed
his backside against the dirt trying to
get off whatever that substance was or
at least
mesh the dirt in in today's era of
sticky stuff they're trying to be above
board and communicate
as much as possible that may be a first
that i've ever seen got him looking
strike three
call a ten page ending
a second straight minimum face frame
with two strikes here's the one two and
that's a curveball and that will end the
inning
he catches suarez looking watching sonny
gray first two pitches of this at bat
grunted next two pitches which is what
he threw for strikes no grunt
that time went back to the grunt
there's a grunt there's a foul tip
strike three and peterson parks
larger lead in second swinging
off speed up six strikeouts for gray
got a cash in here taylor is strikeout
victim and bounced into a double play
first pick swinging a base head into
that field
going to score a couple of runs aureus
is in
following as adamus and the brewers do
cash in tyrone taylor
and there's a smash down the right field
line that'll be extra bases
that'll score a pair bradley turns
second digging for
third and a two-run triple for
jackie bradley jr to make it a
five-nothing game
trying to put away mike freeman with
akiyama the runner at first here's the
o2
got him and that's out number two here's
the one-two pitch
got him another strikeout for corbin
burns give him
seven here this afternoon
[Music]
standing players for the reds ball club
here's the ground wanted to last chance
to get two in the return throw
yes sir three six three you get jesse
winker
there's that left-handed throwing first
base and that comes in handy on a play
like that
2-2 pitch and it's gonna cost him yes
sir another strikeout for burns
give corbin eight of them this afternoon
christian yelich
set to lead off this top of the seventh
inning for the crew
christian yelled sending one deep to
center field there you go
it is gone christian yelich
over the wall in center field
we talked about it last night his work
in the late innings maybe that'll get
him going
four-game separation on friday night
brewers have a chance to kick back to
seven if they can finish the job today
and suarez offers and that's another
strikeout for corbin burns
after the first pitch softly a line
drive to willie adamus
reds go down one two three corbin burns
spinning another beauty here this
afternoon
that is yep got him and that is ten
strikeouts for corbin burns here this
afternoon
burns delivers and another strikeout
make it 11 for corbin through the eighth
inning
today's start the 1-2 pitch to aquino
and that's a goal third strike he
strikes out the side here in the eighth
inning
trying to add to it for corbin burns and
adamus with a fly ball head back into
deep right center field
and it's gone second home run of the
series for adamus
is 11th as a brewer he's now driven in
37.
as a milwaukee brewer one more to get
and a happy flight back to milwaukee
here's tucker barnhart berdoma
ready with a payoff pitch here it is
he struck him out looking and that will
do
it back-to-back strikeouts for perdomo
out of the pen
wrapping up a great day and a terrific
series for the brewers